in July 1918 the Ekaterinburg Reds
feared that a Czech army and white
Russian forces were on their way to
rescue the Tsar the decision was made to
act
Yakov giraffes key was the hardliner
chosen by the local committee to take
over command of the house of exile the
guards known to have become affectionate
towards the family were removed Yurovsky
brought in new men with a new mission to
execute the prisoners in the cellar of
this house in 20 horrific minutes on the
night of July 17 1918 the last chapter
of the Romanovs would be written
just after midnight the Royals are
roused from sleep by guards the family
is told that because of anarchist unrest
in the town
the upper rooms of the house have become
unsafe that there may be shooting in the
streets the Tsar his wife and five
children along with their four
attendants all eleven that make up the
royal household are brought down into
the cellar for their own safety
Yaffe's key and his men enter the room
he has instructed each to shoot a
different family member in the heart to
lessen the blood flow there were
investigations after the event and there
are written accounts as detailed as they
are confusing but what happened here was
both savage and hate-filled
as the smoke cleared the myth began
could anyone really have escaped dis
carnage the bones now found in the coop
keyaki forest may provide the answers to
this question shedding fact from fiction
in a case that has sparked the popular
imagination has proven virtually
impossible but this latest find may give
investigators the evidence they've been
searching for for decades the final
answer hidden in the snowy Siberian
forest for nearly 90 years